I was at a party and somebody used the
phrase oh did the show jump the shark
yeah and I said a guy who works with me
this guy john hein he started that and
they were like and like they didn't
apparently even understand what jump the
shark was cuz they didn't know where the
term came from but they know what it
meant and i explained how he was in
college and they used to talk about when
shows turned bad and jump the shark calm
is something he started he sold it to TV
Guide and now jump the shark his gun TV
got now just if you go to that website
tvguide.com just shows up that's true
and it was frustrating selling it was
tough but I didn't think it would then
you know be just be lost you still
catalog when shows jump the shark I mean
when you're watching TV do you go oh the
show just got bad oh yeah all the time
about Game of Thrones
I say when they when they did that dark
episode that shows [ __ ] jump the
shark very rapidly again you know how
much I loved that show but I think when
that hole got put in the wall at the end
of the second to last season after that
point was not the same what about
Seinfeld out there or is it possible
that a show never jumps the shark it's
rare but name a show that never jumped
the shark Breaking Bad Breaking Bad is
probably one I would say that never
jumped the sharks although I thought
after the guy died in Breaking Bad who
was the kingpin you know yeah once he
was gone I don't think the show was ever
as good as it went on I would say
Breaking Bad never jumped the shark
Gilligan's Island never jumped the shark
when the Harlem Globetrotters came to
play basketball at the island is when
Gilligan's Island
really when did Star Trek jump the shark
the trebles episode a lot of people
think but again very short run was it on
long enough to jump the shark right
understood she's he is kind of fun like
I was thinking ah I shouldn't buy John
Obama say yeah we should have talked to
him about that the night of the party I
know cuz John was kind of quiet at your
birthday party nobody was really talking
to I was watching that I didn't think I
was so
quiet I know you said that but should he
just play jump the shark all night
in fact when this woman said I said you
know maybe I will invite John in one of
my parties and then he can just sit
there and be the entertainment that's
all I'll do just respond to what is the
best show that ever aired on television
of all time the wire is probably the
best show I think of all time the wire
that is a great show that was a great
show
I don't know if all time might be who
knows
you see expert listen he's got the body
to prove it this is a body but guys
watches TV 24 hours a day